One option if we hate our jobs obviously
is to leave it
but if we actually cannot
leave our job for various reasons
the question is:
What are we supposed to do?
Be the leader you wish you had.
Working at a hard job working for a bad boss
can sometimes be one of the greatest
educations ever.
So the question is:
Can you change your mindset?
Instead of waking up in the morning going
"Oh I can't do this again"
but rather view it as university.
You know, you're getting a master's degree in leadership
and you may be learning everything
how not to do things
and to wake up and be like,
"What am I gonna learn today?"
Early on in my career I had a
really bad boss who believed that she
could get the most out of us by berating
us and she told me once that—I had
one of my "reviews"—and she said,
"You have no talent"
and I was like "nothing?"
and she was like "nothing."
This was her way of, I guess, motivating me
but I had such a
good attitude about it for a couple of reasons.
One, because I knew, I think knew, what I was up against every day
and instead of taking it personally
I viewed it as as my education of how not to lead
and I literally would file this stuff
all the way and use it some day.
I get to use it now.
And also, misery loves company.
You know, I had fantastic a fantastic relationship with my team.
We looked after each other because we all had this
the oppressive boss.
We would compare the "advice" that we got in our
little career building sessions and
we took care of each other
and so we had a responsibility to each other
and that's where we cut our teeth on being
leaders and it actually made the job
wonderful.
Yes there were days that were oppressive.
Yes there were days that I hated.
Yes, there were days I wanted to like, pull my hair out and just quit
but it's because of the team that I had
and how we looked after each other
and the mindset of learning every day that I made the most of it.
So I think mindset is a
huge huge huge part of
actually getting some joy out of a difficult job.